Taiwanese people from all walks of life
spending their weekend learning first
aid and survival
during the past year the kuma Academy
has held classes for thousands who are
wary of a potential Chinese occupation
I'm very afraid that next time it will
be our turn
to be like Hong Kong so if there any
some lecture like this to teach how to
defund some thread back from China I'll
just try to participate the threat of an
invasion may not necessarily be imminent
but organizers of the training camp and
those taking part say they don't want to
get caught unprepared
there's always the possibility of an
armed conflict of course there's no
certainty when or if it will happen but
it's good to be ready
to that end the government is also
playing its part it recently released an
updated handbook on civil defense to
teach us how to distinguish between
Taiwanese and Chinese soldiers and it
has a link showing where bomb shelters
can be found
this subway station in Taipei doubles as
an air raid shelter there are more than
5 000 of them all over the city from car
parks to basements anything underground
combined they can accommodate about 12
million people
Rising tensions in the Taiwan Strait
aren't just between China and Taiwan
however earlier this month the U.S
accused the Chinese warship of an unsafe
maneuver after it nearly collided with
an American Destroyer China told the U.S
to stay away from the region and mind
its own business
Taiwanese who overly worry about the
possibility of a premeditated calculated
attack from China what townies are
worried about however is the possibility
of an accidental escalation from all
these Chinese assets airplanes and ships
in Timeless neighborhood
taiwan's president Chang won has
increased engagements with U.S officials
to counter any threat of annexation by
China
but China has responded with more
military activity
now Taiwan will be looking to the U.S to
ease these tensions
barnabilo Al Jazeera Taipei